>> Laura: WILL COME BACK TO
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
THIS MORNING, THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED, THIS IS MY 500TH DAY IN
OFFICE AND WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED A
LOT.
MORE THAN ANY PRESIDENT.
VERY COMPETITIVE.
IN FACT, MOST REPUBLICANS DO
AGREE, BASED ON GALLUP NUMBERS,
TRUMP HAS THE SECOND-HIGHEST
RATINGS EVER BY A PRESIDENT'S
OWN PARTY AFTER THE 500 DAY MARK
AT 87%.
THAT SECOND ONLY TO
GEORGE W. BUSH AND THAT, OF
COURSE, WAS NINE AFTER 9/11.
DOES THIS SPELL TROUBLE FOR
DEMOCRATS AFTER THEY LOST THEIR
BIG LEAD IN THE MIDTERM GENERIC
ELECTION GOAL TELL MY POLLS?
LET'S DIVE IN WITH MATCH LAP,
CHAIRMAN OF THE CONSERVATIVE
UNION AND DEMOCRATIC
-- WE ARE GOING TO DO
OUR REPORT CARDS AS WELL.
500 DAYS IN, MATT, I THOUGHT
TRUMP WOULD DO WELL.
I DIDN'T THINK HE WOULD DO THIS
WELL.
I DID NOT PREDICT.
I PREDICTED HE WOULD WIN THE
PRESIDENCY.
HISTORIC LOWS, THE LIST GOES ON.
JERUSALEM, ALL OF THE STUFF -- I
AM SPEECHLESS ABOUT THAT.
>> I AM AMAZED THAT THE FLOODING
OF DECISIONS, PROMISE MADE,
PROMISE KEPT ON ISSUE AFTER
ISSUE, PRESIDENTS LIKE THE SPACE
IT OUT, TAKE A BREATH.
THIS PRESIDENT -- I HAD TO WRITE
IT ALL DOWN.
COULDN'T KEEP TRACK OF IT.
THERE'S SO MUCH GETTING DONE.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
IT'S AMAZING.
>> Laura: YOUR REPORT CARD FOR
THE PRESIDENT, DO WE HAVE
SEPARATE ROSTERS FOR THEM?
I THINK WE DO.
DOMESTIC POLICY REPORT CARD, YOU
GIVE A PRESIDENT A...
>> AN A.
>> Laura: THE REASON?
>> HOW DO YOU DO BETTER THAN A
GROWING ECONOMY, NEIL GORSUCH ON
THE SUPREME COURT --
THE ONE YOU HAVE YOUR OWN REPORT
CARD.
I LOVE IT.
WHY YOU IN RED?
THAT USUALLY FOR A F.
>> THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
MIGHT NOT WANT TO DEFUND IT OR
TAKE THE STEPS TO DO IT, BUT THE
PRESIDENT IS WILLING TO DO IT.
ON ISSUE AFTER ISSUE AFTER
ISSUE, THE FINAL THING ROLLING
BACK REGULATIONS, THAT'S THE
BIGGEST IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY
AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE GROWING.
>> Laura: THE TAX BILL IN
THERE.
>> GOOD, VERY GOOD.
BIGGER BUT I DO NOT THINK THE
OBAMA REGULATIONS HAD A BIGGER
DAMPENING ON THE ECONOMY.
>> I'M THE 54% OF AMERICA NOT
HAPPY ON THE SIDE OF THE TABLE
FOR YOU GUYS ARE AT 46% THAT IS
HAPPY.
I'M THE 54% THAT IS NOT HAPPY.
>> Laura: TELL US WHY.
WHY YOU GAVE THEM A F.
>> YOU ARE GIVING ME A HARD TIME
DURING THE BREAK AND I SAID, I'M
SORRY, THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
LISTEN, THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
AN ABJECT FAILURE AND HE WILL
YOU MEASURE PEOPLE ENTERED THIS
PRESIDENCY ABLE TO AFFORD THEIR
GAS, THEY CANNOT NOW.
ALSO, THE SOCIAL SECURITY,
MEDICARE HAS BEEN PUT IN REST BY
THE PRESIDENT.
HE HAS BEEN A COMPLETE AND TOTAL
WASHOUT AS A FAILURE AS OF THE
METS GET POLICY PRESIDENT.
I'M SURPRISED ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS HAVEN'T STOOD UP
MORE TO THIS PRESIDENT TO FIGHT
FOR SOME OF THE VALUES THEY
CLAIM TO CARE ABOUT.
>> Laura: HERE IS AN
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICAN, RYAN
COSTELLO FROM PENNSYLVANIA.
TRUMP WON PENNSYLVANIA FIRST
TIME SINCE GW WON IN '88.
>> INSTANCES WHERE YOU SEE
REPUBLICAN PUSHBACK IN THE HOUSE
AND SENATE, I FOUND MYSELF VERY,
VERY FRUSTRATED BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE RIGHT, WE HAVE THE LEFT, BUT
WE DO HAVE A CENTER.
I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS IN THE
CENTER DO NOT KNOW WHAT TO
BELIEVE.
YOU GET YOUR HEAD CHOPPED OFF IF
YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF TRYING
TO USE COMMON SENSE.
>> Laura: HE PICKED UP HIS
MARBLES AND WENT HOME.
HE'S RETIRING.
>> A LITTLE YOUNG TO BE
RETIRING.
>> A LOT OF THESE REPUBLICANS IN
THE HOUSE WHO AREN'T RUNNING FOR
REELECTION, THEY THOUGHT TRUMP
WAS SO ATROCIOUS THAT THEY RAN
OUT OF TOWN.
>> Laura: THAT IS FUNNY!
WE HAVE TO GO TO FOREIGN POLICY.
JOEL, YOU ARE A LITTLE MORE
GENUINE.
MORE GENEROUS.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE THEM MORE THAN
THAT.
>> WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER SEGMENT
FOR THAT.
>> Laura: LET'S LEAVE THAT
BEHIND.
YOU GAVE THEM A D+ PURE WHITE?
>> I PUT THE PLOTS.
I PUT A MINUS, I THINK THE GRADE
IS INCOMPLETE.
WE GOT TO SEE WITH NORTH KOREA.
I'M NOT A FAN OF THIS PRESIDENT.
I'LL GIVE IN THE FIRST PERSON TO
GIVE THEM CREDIT IF HE CAN
ACTUALLY BRING PEACE.
IF HE STABILIZES THE KOREAN
PENINSULA, AND WILL GIVE THEM
CREDIT.
HE'S EMBARRASSED US ON THE WORLD
STAGE.
DESTABILIZE THE MIDDLE EAST --
>> Laura: HOW DID HE
DESTABILIZE US IN THE
MIDDLE EAST?
>> OF LET ME FINISH, I WILL
EXPLAIN.
DESTABILIZE THE MIDDLE EAST --
BE WHEN HE KILLED ICE IS OFF
ICES IS GONE.
ALSO IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE
DEATH OF A LOT OF INNOCENT WOMEN
AND CHILDREN A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO.
>> Laura: OBAMA NEVER --
DRONES -- THE LEFT TRASH OBAMA
FOR DRONES.
FOREIGN POLICY?
VEHICLE B+.
I WOULD SAY -- I DIDN'T GIVE HIM
AN A BECAUSE HE'S UPSETTING THE
APPLE CART.
I'M HAPPY ABOUT NAFTA, I LOVE
NORTH KOREA.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO SEE THE NEXT
STEP IS.
I THINK HE HAS A STEP TO BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL ON FOREIGN
POLICY.
IT'S ABOUT EXECUTION WITH FULTON
AND POMPEO.
>> I WILL MOVE THEM UP TO AC FOR
NORTH KOREA.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON SOMETHING THAT
DEVELOPS AMID REPORTS THAT MANY
PLAYERS REFUSING TO SHOW UP TO
THE WHITE HOUSE TOMORROW,
PRESIDENT TRUMP DISINVITED THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES AHEAD OF
THEIR VISIT TO CELEBRATE THE
TEAM SUPER BOWL WIN.
THE PRESIDENT AND THE STATEMENTS
GO TO THE TEAM OVER THE REFUSAL
TO PROUDLY STAND FOR THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM HANDOVER HEART.
>> IS IT SMART TO JUST INVITE
PEOPLE WHO WERE COMING?
I FEEL BAD FOR THE FANS MADE THE
TRIP TO BE HERE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYBODY IN
AMERICA WHO FEEL SORRY FOR NFL
PLAYERS.
>> Laura: THE NBA IS MUCH
BETTER ABOUT THIS.
>> I WAS AT THE CAVS GAME --
>> Laura: HOW DOES THE NBA
MANAGE TO DO THIS RIGHT?
>> EVEN THOUGH ALL THE EAGLES
WITH THE ENTIRE YEAR, NO ONE
ELSE, NO ONE SAT DOWN TO CHECK
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
NONE OF THEM KNELT.
NONE OF THEM WANT TO BE THERE
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT WANT TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA -- BY THE
WAY, PRESIDENT OBAMA, MANY
PEOPLE DID NOT COME TO THE
WHITE HOUSE OVER THE EIGHT YEARS
OF PRESIDENT OBAMA DID.
DID HE EVER JUST INVITE ONE?
NOT ONE.
THIS GUY IS A SNOWFLAKE.
HE CAN HANDLE CRITICISM.
HE CAN HANDLE A TOUGH CROWD.
IF HE CAN'T HANDLE CARSON ONCE,
HOPEFULLY HE --
>> Laura: I WOULDN'T HAVE
DISINVITED THEM.
FIRST OF ALL, JOEL, HE BEAT THE
CLINTONS, THE OBAMA'S --
VEHICLE YES, HE BEAT THEM BY
MINUS 3 MILLION VOTES.
DID A GREAT JOB.
>> Laura: OKAY, MR. GET RID OF
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
YOU CAN DO THAT NEXT SHOW.
HE BEAT HOLLYWOOD, THE G.O.P.
ESTABLISHMENT, HEAR CLEAR CUT
THE WHOLE FIELD --
>> A RACE TO 43%.
>> Laura: HE'S AFRAID OF
COMPETITION?